doris let's keep an eye on how the
clippers attack that paint
differently with favors in boy mitchell
hotter than fish grease basketball
with confidence and think about it two
of his first three shots were made
jumpers
that opens up the drive game now he's
getting to the mid-range
so all three levels right now working
for donovan mitchell
up against paul george put a couple on
him
get kawhi on your back navigate navigate
quick shooter with the left hand
four to five hours a day chauncey said
it could have been
a reality show i just give major props
to chauncey's wife piper for letting all
those coaches in her house for six weeks
guys
and donovan mitchell drops a bomb on the
clippers
all switched sides that allowed joe to
get to the step back and then
donovan point number 24
from deep and the shot
making in the end this first half with
24 points
and now the switch morris trying to
guard him
sidestep three on the way got it
splashdown
donovan mitchell with 59 points
in the last 40 minutes in this series
he has been indomitable
unstoppable implacable
and simply unbelievable with 13
in that second quarter what a half
because you know that next pass is going
to lead to an easy opportunity
donovan looks comfortable comfortable on
that three
again oh he's setting the building
on fire
because you know that next pass is going
to lead to an easy opportunity donovan
looks comfortable
comfortable on that three o'neal getting
his rest
clarkson on the floor so you've got more
offensive options with clarkson and
donovan battles tough shot by donovan
mitchell
well i've been saying it now in the
third period their pickup point for
donovan it's been much
much higher better attention to detail
not letting
out the shot clock working against
jackson
mitchell with the crossover elevating
with the left
using clock and still finding quality
shots by being aggressive enough
[Applause]
they get the switch he hunts canard on
the switch
mitchell but listen you can't let him
get to his right hand these bank shots
that he
somehow